hi my name is Zach brav and I feel so
honored about being Conan O'Brien's
friend thank you for reading that just
as I dictated it to you minutes ago you
know it was so nice uh you light up a
room I'm gonna say that thank you uh I
had a Christmas party yeah not long ago
and
um at the last second I crashed it well
you didn't cry a mutual friend yes uh
revealed that he said is it okay if I
bring my friend Zach Braff and I said
what do you mean is it okay who's
unhappy to see that crap thank you you
are a very well-liked fellow it was a
very fancy party I mean you have a lot
of friends I know the gag here is that
you need a friend but you have a lot of
fancy friends well that's no those are
that's everyone who's done the podcast
and when you sign the release it says
you have to go to my Christmas party but
it was really but I love the the
phrasing of uh is it okay if Zach Braff
comes well I what happened was our
mutual friend uh said he was going and I
was like wow I love Conan and I'm pretty
sure after all these years I have a
pretty decent sense that Conan likes me
um but I'm not about I'm not
I haven't been invited to the party
because I I didn't I mean first of all I
mean we don't we don't hang out socially
we have a couple times but not that much
but anyway so I said I think and he goes
well you know obviously be respectful
I'll I'll just call and ask and and I
got a yes and I was like oh well now I
gotta now I gotta look good for Conan
yeah and
because I felt like it was a bit of an
audition am I wearing a gorgeous gown
that was a contender for the Emmys and I
said you know what
but you know I saw you and immediately
we're hanging out we're having a really
good time and uh everybody was excited
to see you yeah yeah of course no they
were but uh but I should say I keep
saying our mutual friend or mutual
friend we should reveal it's Mr T Mr T I
wish it was Mr D it was wouldn't it be
cool if the three of us just cruised
around and had fun it's uh it's Bill
Lawrence who um is uh is an incredible
friend of mine and mentor to me and he
created scrubs he created one of the
creators of Ted lasso and it's one of
the creators of this new show shrinking
and he's he's one of my best friends and
also uh been a huge big brother mentor
to me who is also your friend yeah he's
a very good man extremely talented yes
very funny a great guy and uh yeah so I
was so glad that he brought you along
and uh that made me think man we got to
grab this guy for the podcast thank you
and I left the party thinking I need
more cool friends because I only have a
few friends and they're cool I love them
but like you have a lot of cool friends
yeah I guess or it's not just a
Christmas party and you're just really
stacking it yeah yeah it's all stacked
and you see that uh I'm hung out with
Paul Reubens at your house is that crazy
every I met Paul and he's very sweet he
sends me a Christmas card and a birthday
card every single year
um but I never hung out with him
socially other than to meet him very
sweet guy couldn't have been nicer and
he was at your house and I was just like
I can't believe I'm like chilling with
Paul Reubens also the urge to call him
Peewee is so strong I I don't know and
you have to call him he is Paul he's
Paul Rubens and you get used to that but
I'm you know I've been with him when
people are like Pee-Wee
it's not Peewee now he's Paul he becomes
Peewee yeah sorry I did that
well it was Revolution I had I had the
doll that you pulled the string I had
Cherry that you put him in yes uh well
also it was so revolutionary because it
was that show that you could watch on
two levels yes absolutely there were
kids watching it just loving Peewee and
then there were all of us watching it on
this in completely different level so
subversive and cool in a way it was it
was like kind of that before The
Simpsons was that like right right I
mean I feel weird telling you that but
it's like it was it was an early thing
that was kids will get it on one level
adults will get it on another yes
there's all kinds of stuff going on in
The Simpsons that you now watch you know
I mean that's the that's the I think the
secret and The Batman series of the 60s
was the same thing yeah you can watch it
wow Batman got the Joker but when you're
a little older or they when you're
you're seeing it and you're watching it
and you're thinking oh my God the
they're making all this commentary on
all this insane stuff like that's going
on in the world and instead of uh what
is the mayor of Gotham is Mayor Lynn
seed as in linseed oil instead of yeah
Lindsay who is the mayor of you know and
it's also so campy which as a kid I
didn't clock or understand you don't
understand that we're not meant to
understand that yeah but now you watch
it it's hilarious because it's like he
has bat Shark spray on him just when
they encounter the shark you know
[Laughter]